على مدى التاريخ الانساني كانت هناك حروب
ونزاعات مسلحه لكن في القرن الحادي
والعشرين فان الامن البشري والامن السياسي
والامن الغذائي لا يمكنها ان تتحقق عبر
التسليح انفسنا فلا طالما راينا ان كل
الاستجابات العسكريه للازمات والنزاعات
فشلت فقط انظري لمنطقه الساحل الافريقي
مثلا ففي السنوات الاخيره تم انفاق الكثير
من الاموال هناك في مهمات حفظ السلام ولكن
ايضا في برامج عسكريه لدعم القوى الخمس
الكبرى والان ها نحن في عام 2023 والوضع
اصبح اكثر تفجرا فالموقف في مالي وبوركينا
فاسو وكثير من دول الساحل صعب حيث يتنم
التطرف العنيف ينبغي علينا ان نعترف انه
في بعض الاحيان جلب الاسلحه ونشر المزيد
من الاسلحه لا يحل بشكل هيكلي المشكله
ونعرف مبدئيا ان مشاكلها مثل الفقر وعدم
المساواه وعدم قدره المؤسسات الحكوميه على
العمل انتجت فراغا سمح لهذه المجموعات بان
تجد موتها قدم لها بل وان تجند عده اشخاص
ونحاول ربط العلاقه بين كل هذا ففي عام
2017 نشرنا استطلاعنا الاول حول مقاتلين
سابقين تم تجنيدهم من قبل مجموعات متطرفه
وقد وسعنا هذا العمل الان ونشرنا التقدير
الثاني بعد ان قابلنا فيه اكثر من 2000
شاب تم تجنيدهم في ثمان دول على امتداد
منطقتي الساحل والقرن الافريقيين وطرحنا
عليهم سؤالا حول ما الذي دفعهم الى
الانضمام الى هذه الجماعات هناك كانت هناك
خلاصات مهمه جدا الكثير من الناس كانوا
يعتقدون ان الرساله الدينيه كانت عنصر
الجذب الاول عند الانضمام الى هذه
الجماعات لكن في الواقع عندما تتحدث للناس
صغار السن فن العامل الاقتصادي والوضع
الاجتماعي هما العاملان الاهم مثل البطاله
وعدم توفر متطلبات الحياه او الفقر المتقع
هذا هو الدافع الاول وليس الدين في
الحقيقه ما يمثل المشجع الاول
[موسيقى]